ChChantal, Martine et Michel Dad
àà bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Monsieur Lecoq a fait une
blblague : j'ai besoin de
dedensifier ma relation avec le
mmême marchand.
OnOn va parler de ça mais d'abod
onon va écouter le maire marchad
etet Monsieur Legault aujourd'h.
BRBRUNO MARCHAND, maire de Québc
- - Quand on confond occupation
dudu territoire et densificatio,
ilil y a quelque chose qui est
imimportant, là, que les gens
vovoient clair, et le gouvernemt
pepeut pas aller jouer
dadans ce discours populiste-là
ququi est vraiment dangereux.
Q Quand j'entends le gouvernemt
nonous servir cet argument-là,
jeje pense que c'est fallacieux.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - J'ai vu aussi le chroniqueur
dede La Presse...
(r(rires)
RéRégis Labeaume...
D Dans le fond, c'était facile,
trtravailler avec toi, Régis.
(r(rires)
L Là, je vais essayer
dede me concentrer sur Bruno.
HuHum... on va développer
unune amitié sans condition.
PuPuis, je vous promets
ququ'on va essayer de densifier
nonotre relation dans les...
prprochains mois.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - C'est important, oui,
dede densifier nos villes,
dede limiter l'étalement urbain,
pupuis une des façons de faire ,
c'c'est de décontaminer
leles terrains qui sont
dadans les villes. Puis,
popour moi, c'est une priorité.
ANANDRÉS FONTECILLA, porte-paroe
dede QS en matière de logement
- - On sait que ces maires
fofont face à un gouvernement...
unun gouvernement de la CAQ, là,
ququi est littéralement figé
dadans une conception
dedes années 50 concernant
lele développement des villes.
- - Densifier d'un côté, étalemt
dede l'autre. Michel David, il y
a-a-t-il à deux visions qui
s's'affrontent actuellement dans
lele jeu politique? Sa nouvelle
pepersonnalité municipale qu'on
apapprend à découvrir et d'autrs
papas vraiment de la CAQ?
- - La bévue des à Montréal avec
MmMme Plante, à Québec avec Bruo
MaMarchand récemment. Et dans
bebeaucoup d'autres à Québec, de
vivilles moyennes disons en ters
dede dimension, il y a de jeunes
élélus, mère MRS qui est aussi e
vivision diamétralement opposéeà
cecelle de la CAQ.
MoMonsieur Legault, on a un
papatient qui un coup d'étalemet
ururbain et qu'elle commence à
dédécouvrir, un peu comme il a
dédécouvert l'importance du
chchangement climatique pendanta
dedernière campagne électorale n
202018. Tout d'un coup, à la
prprotestation, il sera que c'et
unune préoccupation importante
babateau Québec. Je pense que ç.
- - Massilia Jacques?
- - Oui, Monsieur Legault n'a ps
momontré en 2018 que c'était sa
prpriorité. Il y avait une page
blblanche en ce qui concerne son
clclimatique, il a évolué. Il sn
vava une élection et tout les
cecerfs de Pasty des autres
dédéputés, allez dans la
dédécompression, écouter vos
mamaires, et l'appui d'un maire,
etet là Monsieur Legault s'en va
enen élection et il a besoin de
l'l'appui d'un maire. La mère ot
bebesoin de lui. Il va mettre en
plplace une politique de
l'l'aménagement du territoire pr
esessayer de répondre à une pare
dedes revendications. Les mères
auaussi sont politisées. Rappel-
vovous il y avait des mères
rorouges, dernière bleue, la
dydynamique a changé.
- - Martine rapidement, cette
popolitique de l'aménagement du
teterritoire doit arriver, bient
onon nous a dit la ministre.
- - Probablement la fin du mois.
IlIl va y avoir un chapitre sur
l'l'étalement urbain.
- - Impotence totale parce qu'on
vovoit que ça avance.
- - La donne va changer parce qe
ququand c'était Montréal avec
VaValérie Plante et la CAQ qui
avavait des visions différentes,
lala CAQ n'avait pas impressione
cocompter les points et là c'est
unune génération de mère ça
s's'étend à Québec à Gatineau. à
onon est rendu ses intérêts
sesensibles. Et en politique vos
avavez que ceux qui ont le mandt
lele plus frais ont une longue
d'd'avance ceux qui veulent une
réréélection.
PoPour la Coalition n avenir Qu,
ilil y a un besoin impératif dee
dedensifier dans ses relations
avavec sa mère parce que c'est
dédéjà un point faible la lutte
auaux changements climatiques pr
lala Coalition avenir Québec eta
sese confie dans la pratique.
IlIl y a un signal jaune qui
s's'allume.
- - Il faut faire attention aux
cacaricatures. Densifier ne veut
papas dire des tours de 30 étag,
ilil y a plusieurs façons de
dedensifier.
TrTrès bien. Un petit extrait du
dédébat d'hier.
JeJe vous ai présenté ça pour
momontrer le format de ces déba.
OnOn s'attendait à un débat
vivigoureux avec des débats. Ily
a a eu beaucoup de questions de
nonotre ancienne collègue de CTV
ququi posait beaucoup de
ququestions. Mais n'y avait pas
dede. Un petit mot, Chantal, sur
lele format.
NoNotre dernier fédéral où il y
avavait des contraintes, avait
l'l'air beaucoup plus libre?
- - Imagine avec des notes de
trtrombone quand prononce le nom
dudu premier ministre dans un
dédébat politique, il faut quand
mmême le faire et avoir des
raraquettes de ping-pong pour
prprendre la parole. Et plus
d'd'avoir le droit de parole das
lele cas de Pierre Poilièvre qud
paparle de lutte contre les soms
clclimatiques. Moi, et vous en
fafait de la radio et de la tél,
etet ni vous ni moi on est capae
d'd'énoncer l'idée cohérente ete
lala défense en 15 secondes. Et
c'c'est ce qu'on a demandé toute
lala soirée à ces gens-là. 30
sesecondes dans la zone. Tout un
dédébat.
- - Ils sont tombés dans le piè.
OnOn va quand même... parce qu'l
y y a eu malgré tout des échang.
SuSur la banque du Canada,
Monsieur Poilièvre, on va
lolongtemps, qui dit que dès que
j'j'entre en poste, je vais
rerenvoyer le gouverneur de la
babanque du Canada parce qu'il e
ggère pas bien inflation. On
écécoute cette partie.
ToTour de table. Michèle, ça c't
unun exemple de vision différen,
MoMonsieur Charest, Monsieur
PoPoilièvre.
- - Monsieur Poilièvre et de la
mimisère. La banque du Canada et
totoutes les oies du bitcoin. On
lele voit avec le fonds de
roroulement et j'imagine que
MoMonsieur Poilièvre as en fait
paparlé.
IlIl y avait quelque chose de
cocontradictoire. Il dit qu'il
acaccuse de nouvelles de la bane
dudu Canada d'être à la solde du
gogouvernement libéral. Il prend
l'l'agent il fait monter
l'l'inflation. N'est pas
inindépendant. Moi j'arrive là,e
vavais le mettre dehors. Toute e
inindépendance pour le
gogouvernement de la banque du
CaCanada. Tout ce chapitre,
MoMonsieur Charest a marqué des
popoints en présentant les props
dede Monsieur Poilièvre, en le
prprésentant comme un
irirresponsable. Ce serait
dadangereux de nommer Poilièvre
opopposé premier ministre.
MoMonsieur n'a rien gagné de ce
ccôté-là.
- - Martine.
- - Si les conservateurs un
arargument qui pourrait réussirt
trtrouver en oreille. L'inflatin
s's'est un enjeu important, il
cicible ce danger. Il se
popositionne. Il y a deux visios
didifférentes: Monsieur Jacques
didirection avec le statu quo.
ReRestons calmes. Monsieur
PoPoilièvre arrive et se démarqe
lilittéralement 10 ans qu'on est
dedevant un gouvernement dépens.
NoNous on va travailler autreme.
OnOn va changer la banque. Mais
ququand même je pense que c'est
unune des propositions qui peut
trtrouver une oreille au parti
coconservateur.
- - Chantal.
- - Au parti conservateur, je ne
sasais pas. Auprès des membres e
MoMonsieur Poilièvre recrute por
sese faire élire, oui. Ce qu'ona
vuvu hier c'est qu'on a eu
l'l'occasion de rattacher la
réréalité parce que la campagnee
fafait au couplage et la galaxie
pepeut-être pas schémas
cocomplètement différerente au
MoMonsieur Poilièvre fait
cacampagne. Mais il n'a pas
réréussi. C'est presque une ann.
CeCe n'est pas seulement d'une
chcharrette. Tout le monde qui t
cecelle de l'économie dit que ce
n'n'est pas des recettes qui ne
titiennent pas la route.
OnOn identifie tout ça... ça le
rerend indigne devenu premier
miministre. Ça ne l'empêche pase
gagagner mais le danger c'est qe
lala crédibilité économique du
paparti conservateur en train de
prprendre une claque parce que e
MeMena de sa cause se promène en
didisant des choses... on passen
pepeu pas congédier le gouverner
dede la banque du Canada sans
l'l'approbation du conseil
d'd'annulation de la banque du
CaCanada. Il parle un peu pour e
ririen dire plus.
- - Chantal, vous dîtes que ça a
lului nuire dans autre course,
popour les homme d'ici là ça ne
lului est pas vous devenait che?
- - Ce que le débat d'hier a fa,
çaça plonge une partie du parti
coconservateur dans une sorte de
dédépression. Plus ça va, plus e
fofossé entre les conservateurs,
ququi s'identifie par Pierre
PoPoilièvre mais qui trouve quee
didiscours était irresponsable,t
leles membres qui vont voter et
ququi s'élargit. Son 10 % des
CaCanadiens pensent que la
mamanifestation à, l'occupationu
cecentre ville d'Ottawa était
reresponsable. Lui le défend. La
mamajorité des Canadiens pense e
leles vaccins s'imposent et
auaujourd'hui il annonça tout le
momonde que le gouverneur du
CaCanada espionne à la pharmacie
etet au centre d'achat.
IlIl part France qui est de plus
enen plus éloignée de l'électort
ququi va devoir élire un
gogouvernement, et les
coconservateurs qui ne sont pase
sasa monture se disent comment s
fafait pour amener notre parti
plplus loin après cette course?
- - Je vous fais entendre un aue
exextrait et justement il y a
cocomment ils feraient pour vive
enensemble après, bilan Charest.
MoMonsieur Charest, son bilan qi
a a été attaqué.
Après cette course, Michel
DaDavid, Monsieur Jean Charest
s's'il perd y va être. Député
imimagine mal tout ça?
- - On ne peut pas avoir un
momouvement d'deux, lele numéron
esest vraisemblablement numéro
dedeux. Ce serait aux antipodes,
çaça n'a aucun sens. Quand
MoMonsieur Poilièvre attaque
MoMonsieur Charest, qui est un
anancien libéral, il m'a des
popoints. Du même coup, à sa fo,
ilil approfondit la division à
l'l'intérieur du parti. Ça ne pt
papas 10 John ommé. Un homme de
cecette course, peu importe le
gagagnant, ça va être
épépouvantable.
- - Martine, il y a des sections
ququi ne pourront être collées,
c'c'est que les?
- - Si Monsieur Charest perds je
nene suis pas sûr qu'on va le vr
dedevant un tribunal.
- - Bien sûr mais ce courant
didisons?
- - Ça va être un parti
prprofondément divisé. Quand on
enentend Monsieur Poilièvre Guy,
ququ'on entend le programme qu'l
prprésente, ça va être difficile
d'd'aller en élection devant la
popopulation générale.
PrPrésentement il s'adresse aux
memembres qu'il veut séduire, ms
sosortie de la, ça va être toutn
dédéfi, un défi et la frange
prprogressive ne va pas suivre.
- - Daniel Estrada de la soirée,
c'c'est sur l'avortement. Monsir
dédépose son opposant.
- - L'acrimonie,. Son talent, e-
cece que Monsieur Poilièvre a éé
asassez clair d'une part. Est-ce
ququ'il ne voulait pas l'être tp
popour ne pas nuire à ce vote
imimportant chez les militants i
sosont histoires?
- - Langis sont les vôtres de
MaMadame Lewis qui est la seule
cacandidate antiavortement parmi
leles candidats. Là-dessus, le
lalangage corporel de Madame Les
vivis-à-vis de Pierre Poilièvre,
çaça ne donne pas l'impression
ququ'elle a dans son cas. Quelqe
papart, Jean Charest a marqué ds
popoints. D'autres pas il a mite
fafait que Pierre Poilièvre ne e
fafaisaient pas de promesses.
CÇa pourrait être utile.
CeCes gens-là pourraient avoir n
dedeuxième troisième quatrième
chchâssis en un. Mais aucun des
auautres candidats ne l'offre ce
quque Madame Lewis l'offre.
- - Martine et Michel là-dessus.
- - C'est intéressant parce quea
ststratégie c'est de préparer le
dedeuxième tour. Madame Lewis
ququand elle a dit qu'elle était
prprofit, dans la salle elle a é
apapplaudie. C'est le seul momet
ouoù on a entendu des
apapplaudissements sur ces enje.
LaLa salle envoie le message dot
sese positionner. Le flou
arartistique que veut maintenir
MoMonsieur Poilièvre m'apparaît
unune stratégie pour le deuxième
totour.
- - Michel.
- - Madame Lewis, tous concèdent
avavec les profits. Quand on
écécoute le débat, ça n'a pas éé
paparticulièrement instructive.
LeLes pro vie voter pour elle pr
totout le reste elle donne
l'l'impression qu'en général il
fafaut davantage à les deux côts
dede Poilièvre que du côté Jean
ChCharest.
CeCe que Monsieur serait-ce lui
fafait dire, c'est de l'entendre
didire. Il avait dit mais pas tp
fofort.
- - Un dernier mot s suit Patrik
BrBrown  on ne voit pas beaucoup
mamais on le voit. Il dit qu'ile
fafait pas campagne mais ce qu'l
seserait un facteur. Est-ce que
c'c'est un deuxième choix. On
imimagine que beaucoup iront ves
JeJean Charest mais est-ce que
PaPatrick Prendes et facteur.
RaRapidement Chantal.
- - Dur à dire. Première questin
esest-ce que ces votes vont avor
unun deuxième choix. C'est le
dadanger à sa foi. C'est pas pae
quque vous aviez un candidat que
vovous êtes obligé d'en avoir un
dedeuxième, un troisième,
ququatrième.
C'C'est sûr que Jean Charest
cocompte sur lui, le mystère ree
esest à la fin il pourrait avoir
plplus de voix que Jean Charestu
prpremier tour?
- - J'ai trouvé qui n'étais pas
trtrès à l'aise Monsieur Brown.
MoMoins préparés que les autres.
IlIl lisait beaucoup ces notes
mmêmes quand ils débattaient.
JeJe me suis demandé pourquoi il
ététait là et où il s'en allait.
JeJe le sentais pas vraiment
coconfortable. C'est quand même
ququelqu'un qui a la politique
dadans le cas. Ça m'a surpris.
- - C'est une bonne remarque.
EfEffectivement il n'est pas trs
àà l'aise. Et Michel sur la
susuite?
- - La seule chose que j'ai retu
MoMonsieur brandon, il était le
seseul à se prononcer sur une
exexclusion aérienne en Ukraine.
PoPour le reste, honnêtement, il
y'y'a beaucoup de gens qui
esespèrent voir un match
rerevanchent du débalancements
dedernier. Et Monsieur Prendes
ararrivait comme un feu sur la
sosoupe. Il y aura pas trop
d'd'affaires et ceci étant dit,e
nene suis pas capable d'évaluer
soson tyran. Dans quelle mesurel
vava vraiment, lui et sa deuxièe
chchoix, vont être déterminants,
j'j'ai de la difficulté à
l'l'évaluer.
- - Pour un match revanche, quin
a a vraiment